pubmed is the most heavily used
biomedical citation database
in the world guiding over two and a half
million users per day
to the latest advances in life sciences
research
we're constantly improving pubmed to
meet the needs of its diverse user base
and to take advantage of ever evolving
internet technologies and standards
the latest version of pubmed released in
may 2020
is the product of hundreds of hours of
stakeholder engagement
and research undertaken to give you a
better experience
and it's not the first time we've made
big changes from its humble beginnings
in 1997
pubmed now comprises more than 30
million biomedical literature citations
from medline
life science journals and online books
these citations may include links to
full-text content
in pubmed central and publisher sites to
take you directly to the information you
need
to be sustainable going forward the
latest release of pubmed required major
changes
including new databases web architecture
and
cloud delivery combined these changes
resulted in a much more resilient
version of pubmed with a modern design
that looks
and works great on your desktop your
laptop and your mobile device
we realize this feels like a big change
but we've been working hard to help
everyone make the transition to the new
site and have continued to make
improvements along the way
here are a couple new and revamped
features designed to improve the user
experience
the new site button makes it easy to
retrieve styled citations
you can copy and paste into a document
or download an
mbib file to use with your reference
manager software
using the cite button for an item will
open a pop-up window where you can copy
the citation
formatted in four popular styles
automatic
term mapping also called atm was present
in the legacy pubmed
but it's been expanded to include
additional british and american
spellings
singular and plural word forms and other
synonyms to provide more consistent and
comprehensive search retrieval just as
we've done for the past 24 years
we'll continue to add features and data
to stay current
as technology publishing standards and
our users needs evolve
and if you want to see what new updates
have been released as well as what's
coming down the pike
be sure to follow the pubmed new and
noteworthy
rss feed for updates on the latest
enhancements
you